la ciencia fue uno de los tres
protagonistas hoy en la copa 27 y a
propósito un grupo de expertos reveló un
informe sobre los 10 aspectos más
importantes de la ciencia del clima en
él el programa mundial de
investigaciones climáticas la liga por
la tierra y Future Earth le recomiendan
a los negociadores ciertos conocimientos
Uno de ellos es que es falso el mito de
que la adaptación es ilimitada como se
cree y que muchas veces se dice que es
tan solo por falta de recursos
económicos Pero estos expertos enseñan
que los extremos que los eventos pueden
ser tan extremos que no habrá adaptación
posible también Hablamos de ciencia
climática con Edwin Castellanos el autor
líder del capítulo para Centroamérica y
Sudamérica del reporte que hizo el ipcc
sobre vulnerabilidades y adaptación
Además él nos dijo Por qué es importante
actuar ahora
lo que los reportes están mostrando Es
que muchos de los impactos que
pensábamos que iban a ocurrir más tarde
están ocurriendo ya es decir se está
acelerando el proceso de impactos en
parte porque el calentamiento está
ocurriendo mucho más rápido de lo
esperado entonces cosas que se habían
pensado que iban a ocurrir en el año
2040 2050 Entonces estamos viendo ya
actualmente eso también está mostrando
la urgencia de actuar el informe al
final de cuentas eso es lo que enfatiza
es urgente que actuemos ahora